my name is Jorge loboda and I'm the
co-founder of Jen's lounge in Los
Angeles California
whenever off we're always working all
the things I kind of see when I'm out
and about turn into JSON segments I read
a quote once from Will Smith where he
said I don't consider myself necessarily
the most talented person
I think I'm above average talented but I
will outwork the next person 100% of the
time you know when that guy is off
partying hey George what's good man how
you doing good to see you man what we're
doing today but ah just need a little
weight taken out of the top and cleaned
up on the side probably like a little
low and tight woman do it look sharp
I love the aesthetic of this place from
you know the vintage barber chairs the
subway tile on the walls
it just feels classic and clean back in
the 80s there was these books written by
Charles Hicks and he wrote a series of
guides for men you know grooming guides
fashion guys in the grooming guys there
was different hairstyles what they were
called how to talk to your barber how to
ask for them when I was reading if I
really thought guys today need something
like this and that was kind of the
inspiration for gents lounge
well we kind of try to bring them to the
guy of today